comme une historique de la ville
nouvelle de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
verrière compte plus de 6000 habitants
une ville touchée par des problématiques
sociales un taux de chômage de 16 % le
taux de pauvreté atteint près de 24%
l'insertion et l'emploi des verriers
roide de sujets sur lesquels la future
majorité pour agir en collaboration avec
d'autres collectivités
un sujet lié à l'éducation et la
scolarité dès le plus jeune âge la lutte
contre la délinquance est aussi un sujet
pris en compte par les candidats la
verrière touchée aussi par le phénomène
de désert médical le manque de médecins
et de professionnels de santé sur la
commune pose des difficultés d'accès aux
soins des projets d'aménagement sur la
ville d'abord la rénovation du quartier
du bois de l'étang un sujet qui divise
d'un côté une rénovation sur les
bâtiments existants
de l'autre une destruction
reconstruction partielle de certains
immeubles autres quartiers de la
verrière orly parc concerné par
plusieurs projets d'aménagement
autre projet d'urbanisation
intercommunale menée conjointement avec
saint quentin en yvelines le projet
urbain gare bécane 1800 logements une
zone d'activité économique et un pôle de
transport multimodal
juste à côté le carrefour de la malle me
donne attendu pour 2026 le réaménagement
du site prévoit son enfouissement la
verrière maurepas et coignières
actuellement séparés par la nationale 10
seront reliés